crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every to see you
already know though or I encyclia soccer
star JUCO above ground crew goes better
than most Jay Larson self-diagnosed go
download this week last week here we go
again [ __ ] the crab feast
Oh
yeah yeah
welcome back to the crab feast y'all
know shuffle mother tuesday i'll cry
fees for that ass oh you did like to get
like elevator action oh my god Pop's
excited I was like oh I think I like you
were shooting ducks oh good to touch all
those levels of pitches jailers use well
sickle cell great to touch that pitch
hope y'all touching on pitches out there
great to be here with you as always Jay
Larson comic con Jay Larson comedy on
social media I said it last week about
the invitation I just want to let people
know in certain cities right now playing
in Brooklyn Chicago cleveland columbus
detroit oakland omaha portland salem
mass salem s tucson vancouver Yonkers
all right now playing the invitation is
out right now in your towns otherwise
you get on video and demands great movie
that i was in i'm very happy to promote
it and very proud of it and then coming
out after the 20th from like the 20th to
the 29th a bunch of other cities i've
posted it but just real quick Sioux
Falls Charlotte North Carolina Winnipeg
Asbury Park New Jersey Halifax champaign
illinois Kalamazoo Lubbock Texas New
Orleans Palm Springs san antonio san
diego st. Louis Winchester Virginia el
paso texas DC Oklahoma City pittsburgh
tacoma a lot of places why don't you is
there post up on my half not on the
feast website as well i'll put opee I'll
put one up on the feast anyway go check
it out the invitation you'll also can
see it on demand very proud of it
standard wise may twentieth lb Nashville
at zanies for two shows with Nick Thune
Nate bargatze and Rory Scovel Ryan I'll
be a bridge town doing a live podcast on
june fourth i'll be doing stand-up on
the second and third up there bridgetown
and then dublin coming at you 27 to the
30th of july and then I'll be in London
the 31st to the second of august so
those of me sickle cell do you Ryan
Sickler on Twitter Instagram Facebook
Ryan Sickler calm next stand up crab
feast stand up show at the comedy store
is May third come
one out May third lineup is going to be
another great one there I've got that
they're all going to be stupid they're
all going to be five bucks and I'll tell
you I really enjoyed hearing you guys
talk about how great you thought the
lineup was and then hanging out on the
porch and getting to meet you guys and
hearing your favorite stories from the
podcast it's really cool to have that
experience if you're here in LA so thank
you man you guys are always great
respectable fans you really are you're
good you're great you make us proud yeah
man tonight's live crab feast podcast
the Hollywood improv had to be canceled
we will have one in May will be getting
the info for that and we'll let you know
about that tickets for all shows are on
Ryan Sickler comment the crab feast calm
and as always there were a bunch of
there were some ladies rocking Josh wolf
went up and joked around that we had a
bunch of beer to do this but there were
ladies in the second row I have it
Tuesday shirts on so thank you for
buying your merch and rocking that ship
proud we really appreciate it and the
Amazon link thank you so much it helps
tremendously love the feedback from the
premium apps they're all available for
iTunes and on itunes users that's all
right there on the website the facebook
fan page follow us all your craft fees
news will be there just like Jay
Larsen's movie the invitation you can
find information probably they're not
imagine iTunes page your goddamn five
star reviews are the best you guys are
the best a great sponsor this week
seatgeek if anyone's ever had to buy
tickets to a sporting event seatgeek is
the place to go they pull all the
tickets available on other sites into
one place so you can save time and never
miss a deal you can even set alerts for
upcoming events and see geek will let
you know if ticket price falls even
better every ticket on seatgeek is
ranked based on value so you can
immediately find under priced seats and
before you buy you can use seat geeks
detailed maps to see and view from your
seats best of all seatgeek is always
honest and upfront about the price
unlike stubhub they show you all the
full ticket price from start to finish
and never try to trick you with huge
fees on the checkout page which is
something we've always seen when we r
you
yes on tickets for comedy right there's
always like these hidden fees ck-star
large on top exactly they pull
everything into one place for to make it
easier for you here's our deal our
listeners get a twenty-dollar rebate off
their first seatgeek purchase Sam ok
which is yeah it's awesome get twenty
dollar rebate on tickets it's what you
gotta do download the free seatgeek app
go to the Settings tab and click add a
promo code enter promo code crab
seatgeek will send you twenty dollars
after you've made your first ticket
purchase download the free seatgeek app
and enter promo code crab today do it do
it you know what we're gonna do we're
going to bring in our guest this week
fellow ATC member in the podcast
community got some a great history you
know it means a great history
interesting guy so please welcome for
the first time on the crab feast mr.
crisp Mancini welcome to the crappy
crappy great to be here guys first time
comedy film our time listener first-time
guest yeah that's right you now complete
the comment fendler awesome what's your
favorite episode I'm just kinda struck
by lightning last week that's a condor e
dot don't you wish you struck by
lightning you know what I I was hoping
one you guys was making say Shazam I um
I don't the closest I've been one time I
may have said this before but I was
redoing a phone jack an apartment and I
didn't have wire you know strippers yeah
and I'd done it a million times before
put it in my teeth and slide that vinyl
all and man I had the copper too long
and it just just picked my tongue and it
went boom am I'm like a black cat you
know doc Packers went off in my mouth I
was like come on okay okay like yeah you
look under hole in it is it black
and it was I have black on my foot like
it [ __ ] yeah I was like never again
called [ __ ] that so I mean that's not
close to get hit by lightning I'm what
I'm saying you got shocked uh that's
right right not now being shocked I
don't ever want to be for you said don't
you wish you poor you got yes but that's
like literally I guess you gotta taste
yeah this is like you like me to God I
got shot one time like aw dude I almost
got shot too like what happened like I
had a heart attack like it's pretty
close pretty close the same thing though
I'm in shock as shocked you know yeah
but lightning I'm saying you know I'm
saying that little isn't that little
touch I taste I had it was enough to not
be sure that was like an electricity
warning true yeah it sure as [ __ ] was
yeah that's what it was well thank you
very much for being here why don't you
go ahead and tell everybody whatever
you'd like them to know about Chris
Mancini absolutely been a writer a
filmmaker and a comedian I've been doing
the comedy film alerts podcast with
grandma would for many years and we also
help run the LA podcast festival and
we've got a documentary coming out
earbuds the podcasting documentary but
the thing I'm working on right now that
wasn't last year that came out I was
with it finished last year right we had
a preview screening got a festival last
year and then we hit some delays in
delayed action isn't that weird
especially an indie film Ashley in post
/ yeah and when you're on a very strict
limited budget it's so weird that the
way things slow down when you don't have
a hundred thousand dollars to pay
everyone in post-production where there
are a hundred people that you all of a
sudden need to pay so the thing I'm
working on right now is a graphic novel
it's on Kickstarter right now called
long ago and far away and one of the
things that always fascinated me was
like you know as a kid you would read
books about Narnia and oz and the kids
would always go into that world fight
the witch and then come back to our
world well I always thought well what
happens to those kids when they get
older what if they now that they're 30
they run a comic book store and they're
[ __ ] and now they have to go back
into that world and now it's now they're
like hitting on the witch queen and
they're like making [ __ ] worse instead
of like actually helping not been saving
the world so it was kind of that weird
one that like that's I
have to make this it was you know
screenplay was in development in
animation houses but it never got to the
finish line so I'm like so I'm
kick-starting it so I was really excited
to get it going and then as I'm writing
it I was thinking all writing is
autobiographical at some point as you're
writing and I'm it the theme started to
emerge of like as we're kids we have the
sense of childhood wonder like about how
we feel about the world and then we
become jaded adults what happens to us
you know when that happens how do we
regain kind of that childhood wonder
which is a part of us as we grow up as
adults so this is also the story of kind
of regaining that after you've lost it
to cynicism and movies like Batman vs
Superman gigi is so [ __ ] angry oh I
still get I haven't seen I've seen the
preview for that movie I don't haven't
seen anything about it but all I keep
thinking is like why are they fighting
oh my god that's the only question I I
knew it was coming so much it was
actually if you know anything about
writing comic books they there's preview
pages on the Kickstarter page I put his
ax night or joke in there months ago
because I knew what was coming why do I
you do things with a joke I knew I knew
who's going to be [ __ ] they just see
also predicted 911 yeah a lot of things
man seen wait a minute so are you doing
all the drawings as well no hired an
artist too Fernando Pinto from Chile and
he's amazing let me tell you something
right now we're big fans yeah Pinto man
sketch yourself on in here man so yeah
he's amazing it's weird finding a comic
book artist uh the good ones are
unavailable the bad ones are available
but flake so it was really hard to find
when I finally found a good one you know
I knew his given podcast fan really knew
about you know of our podcast he was a
fan so oh good I don't have to explain
any of the humor now yes is perfect so
he came on board and you can check out
like there's preview pages there's all
the artwork is on there and he's he's
just amazing it's really look out
podcasting is changing everything you
just found your artist I know isn't it
amazing a lot of the artists i found a
mark waid who's like a big comic book
writer he found the book to he like
endorsed it like through podcasting one
of the people to work with him I think I
saw that ad on my channel for the other
I endorse this mess alcohol mark wacom
so it's been really cool so I think it
you guys you guys have a fair amount of
listeners I think and a few of them are
probably nerdy comic book fans a few
well not only that my graphic novels are
think a little bit different than comic
books don't you think yes because I mean
I think I've said that to someone one
time they're like well hold on a second
grab an awful a whole different ball cuz
we were at meltdown and unite with you
they used to give you a conversation and
melt down well you should give you gift
certificate and I was like I'm not
really in the compost someone goes what
about a graphic novel exactly what's the
graphic novel on there like it's you
know it's like one of these I'm like
isn't that a comic book to like dude
this is gonna take two hours sit down
but I just my brother was big in a comic
books as a kid he was an artist and he
made his own comic book when he was in
second grade and like I ran into a kid
out here that I went like I grew up with
till 5th grade and then he moved he was
my brother's year till 5th grade right
so I knew him and but it had been 25
years or something when I ran into him
and I so someone introduces it oh you
guys are both Boston guys ne ne I go
what's your name man i'm jane he goes
hey I'm Andrew and as soon as you said
I'm Andrew I go this is andy elf this is
andy elves right here in elves elves
that was named Andy out like more than
one else yes and I'm sitting there and
I'm at this bar and like I had heard
about this kid that was from Boston yet
people like at this other bar like you
should meet this kid so we're sitting
there and I realized right away who he
is right and I go so where you from in
Boston he goes why just I moved out of
there in fifth grade but I used to live
you know just outside I go what what
town he goes stone I'm like oh yeah like
what street and he goes oh you know
stone I'm like I know a little bit and
he goes I grew up on waterhouse road I
go like what over they would like Jeff
folk on and Adam harassment she does
what how do you know
dude I'm Jay Larson my brother's adam
lanza he goes dude walkies and I go what
and he goes your brother used to draw
walkies and make comic books walkies and
he went over grab a piece of paper and
drew wonky because my character get my
brother created these guys called
walkies and then broke like I'm not
kidding like 30 comic Wow like to Guan
keys I mean my brother still he's an
artist as we does for work but like he
was in the comic books I remember used
to have his comic books and I boots this
one it was some bear that used to kick
people's ass I camera cool but that's I
was never got into it but I always watch
my brother like in my house it was like
Adams the artist right you know I mean
at least that's the way I saw like Jay
play sports adamjee artist right but
like every Saturday morning when he get
up 6am to paint with that guy on
Saturday mornings I'd get off yeah oh
yeah I get up and I just lay on the
couch and watch my brother paint you
know I mean my physical you know but um
anyway so I don't have know a lot about
comic books but just through watching my
brother and stuff but it's such a such a
cool way to tell stories you know it's
really cool and it was is something I
was like as far as like converting it
from like a screenplay or whatever you
realize that it's a 200 million dollar
film but in a comic book you know you're
basically giving the storyboards and
creating this whole entire world on some
pages for a fraction of the cost yeah
yeah you know what i like about 22
things real quick one you have there's
no limits there's no rules like
animation there's no rules you want to
make somebody fall through the floor
into the ground gut and the other thing
i like about comic books i tried doing
the series called still life life where
I would tell like make videos but there
were still photos voiced over you know
right and the thing about a comic book
is similar in that way like in a movie
you can take your eyes off you don't
have to watch it but a comp book you
have to look at every detail and as
you're reading you have to watch you
know like you really absorb it which is
a different way to experience i'm
watching like an animated movie now did
you guys like read comic books as kids
july grow up on them but you not miss
that whole thing I just have to miss
anything I just said I I meant like
spider-man like the I I didn't want I
didn't read did you i didn't i would i
would say i checked in on him you know
what i mean every now and then i would
really like i never I was more into
baseball cards than going a calm
book you know but every now and then I
would you know that's and that's exactly
what I get like an Archie or and I was I
ended up getting into mad magazine and
things like that that had elements of
that but I was never a comic book nerd
right right so I am but I really did
appreciate the back of the man magazine
cover that you could be gonna fold in
yeah that's not a picture yeah those
were the two the two famous things was
the the Matt Matt fold in and then every
comic book had this ad of like all these
soldiers you could buy for like two
dollars you know in this but you know I
don't know anyone who ever ordered them
over Gotham datchet like the bag of
green Play um so in addition to a a
comic book you actually done quite a bit
you wrote a movie yes called a silent I
did I felt about yeah technically I did
yes oh yeah now I do write horror movies
too and this was like a straight horror
movie wasn't a comedy there was no
comedy in it it was a straight horror
movie about a SWAT team who investigated
demonic possession in an insane asylum
so sounds right out great pitch b-movie
kind of like an action it was like in
aliens but with you know demonic
possessed a lady's moment monsters one
over the flu yeah yeah exactly so uh i
was i was talking to another dad you
know over after her playdate it was a
casting director and he goes oh yeah i
work with a low budget horror company
and i'll send a script over i'm like
great okay thinking nothing will ever
come of this it's Hollywood but it's
very nice of him to try so he sent the
the script over to after dark films and
a few weeks later not like it already
yeah yeah they they bought it and they
brought me in for a couple meetings may
bottom like I'm like oh this never
happened like as Christ watches kids
free wishes you know I have all these
agents and managers and I sell a script
on a play date all it's the horse right
so I wanted to direct this movie and so
I did this entire presentation
storyboards all this stuff and how I
would direct it how the tone of it would
be like in action after the sale so you
sold the scripts on the script okay I
pitched a director because they wouldn't
guarantee me drop or for the sale but
they said they would consider I said
well that's the best I'm gonna do so i
win
and they pretty much they really liked
the presentation they said I had a
pretty good chance is between me and a
couple other guys okay fine I get a call
they said yeah we're moving the whole
production to Bulgaria and we're hiring
a Bulgarian director okay fine so I
still got that mean that sounds like a
baller move yes yes sup like what was in
Bulgaria location that the what was what
was it about ball shady tax credits
something where you know a million
dollars becomes 500 million right
dollars or whatever something ridiculous
so my orders legal late again the kill
teams are authentic yeah so it's okay so
I don't know yeah it's not fill it
doesn't really look they've already paid
so okay so I don't hear anything forever
so you did you had your chick I got my
check I got paid i got paid for the
script I was like all right well let's
see you know at least like I'm getting a
feature film made it's a it's a you know
in the horror genre what could possibly
go wrong so I don't hear from him for a
while then like a year later I get a
call from the production company hey
could you come in as like why did you
hear later a year later and like okay
I'll come in and yet heard enough fair
enough they didn't update you and I was
on Bulgaria nothing absolutely nothing
and the one thing i did get to see is
they sent a trailer and the trailers
actually it's on YouTube right now and
I'm like well it's not what I would have
done but it's okay it's like a decent
hard you know low-budget arm of a
trailer like okay so I'm thinking wonder
what they want to meet with me about so
I'm about to go to the meeting they
confirm the meeting again I'm about to
leave the house they confirm the meaning
of third time so that only happens when
something is horribly wrong or someone
has a contract out on your life and
wants to make sure that you're going to
be there when they need there so they
can collect the bounty ah so I go
halfway to the meeting they call me
again and go could we just meet at the
bar down the road we don't really want
to meet it in the office like all right
so now I know clearly something has
happened so I get to the bar they start
buying me drinks
and they say to me the producer that
took your script of Bulgaria went rogue
through your script away and shot their
own movie and now we have nothing to
deliver two lions gate Wow and when can
you fix it for us with it had woody mate
wait a minute so they he threw he just
made a whole other movie made all other
movie but the best thing is he kept all
the character names so there's my
there's one originals this guy there
there's American character names all
being cast by a bald Bulgarian guys with
thick x nice so are you saying I rat
yeah but the inner you know it's bad
yeah like all SWAT team names so he
takes your script he throws it away does
his own thing right but does that mean
then that your story minus the character
name is still intact and you can take
that script again and make this fix it
for them or or did he kind of take your
story also know the story literally was
was completely gone everything was gone
everything except the character names
there was not one page of my script that
ended up on screen and a little but the
trailer had some of the elements of my
story okay and I found out why because
after dark after they got all the
russias they're the ones that cut the
trailer together they didn't they try to
piece it together oh my from when they
put their own special effects in and
stuffs on that one goes to you that went
just and YouTube just meeting its room
they put special effects in the trails
to the trailer none of that actually
ended up in the mood how much money they
put in that trailer yeah the trailer had
more money than the film so and the film
was unfinished so there's stuff like
seen missing like a trent reznor video
yeah there's like stock footage there's
guys that are there stock footage yeah
but then they did what they wanted to
pull that out because they want to pay
for that it's so easy and then there's
guys they're supposed to be possessed so
they have white contact lenses but they
ran out of contact lenses so everyone
stoneleigh has one enjoy you know what
hey that's great that is created like oh
you know the greatest give each guy one
man so if they just each have one and 0
and we learn haven't seen that and it
starts Steven Rhea from The Crying Game
really A's actually in the
bulgaria yes Bergere he's the one he's
the one that doesn't have the giant
bulgarian accent so the guy white eyes
that he hadn't up with their yeah he's
aleem yeah he's the lead you don't have
to do contacts but they so they asked me
said can you fix it I said well we think
we think it came out to baby want you to
make it a comedy I said I don't even
know if I can do so and what are they
saying like from the footage they rented
footage they want me to change not just
rewrite a script not just root know
there's there there was like literally
it was it was a mess so who I took an IT
training thing I take it home i watch
the footage I almost threw up it was I
was really close to throwing up they can
like you know you just took one point
four million dollars and threw it down a
Bulgarian well it's pretty much what
they did so I said look there's only one
way I can fix this movie and that is if
I shoot some comedy wrap arounds behind
the scenes at a low budget horror
production company and show how they
[ __ ] up a movie from start to finish
that's good like a mockumentary tight
young and then we should and then
there's two editors watching the rest of
this footage and they're doing mystery
science theater on the shitty footage so
I said that's the only way I can fix
this and I was very surprised when they
went okay it's a shut up how much they
throw that that they didn't want to pay
me to fix it that was the know what were
they gonna give me for a budget to yeah
it was like they would tell me but i
think it was about 10 grand so it was
very low allele very low it was about
probably it was incredibly low so um and
then I said well you know get some
comedians in la well you know we can
make it kind of funny and like no we
want to shoot in Baton Rouge so what do
you mean a thing for being from the
again a weird tax credits and blah blah
blah blah so I can grant turns of the 12
grand oh yeah and this is home and then
this is yet exactly with the draft
services for the credits so their idea
was that comedy is interchangeable I'm
like well just get an improv troupe from
Baton raw egg and then I was just like
everything if and I exactly like I made
in there like you guys don't stop you're
thinking it yes you're making it even
harder every single step of the way so
finally they said but you know we
rolling up the money to pay you and I'm
like
all right here's the deal I want it
fixed and if you're going to let me do
this I can at least I'm writing these
scenes I'm directing it I'm putting it
together you're giving me control of
this and they said okay and they're
gonna give me the rights to my original
script back and let me keep them the
money looks I said okay fine so I i
called the one comedian i know in a Jody
borrello down in New Orleans and I said
can you help me out with this and then
she goes to me you know there's no one
down here right I said I know there's no
comedians done I'm gonna have to
convince them to actually fly out some
talent with me so I managed to convince
them to get Mike Schmidt the comedian he
[ __ ] third baseman from Yale yep my
dad like yeah yeah home run king yeah
from 40 year old boy podcast and I
called my buddy Dean Hagelin from the
x-files just to get some recommendations
when I told him the stories like well
I'm free I'll come down and do it with
you no yeah very cool all right so I got
Dean Hagelin my buddy Mike Schmidt and
then I went down they didn't have enough
to cast me more people I'm in a scene so
so I had to do with scene and then they
didn't want to pay for deep you know
Dean haggle into professional action
perhaps you've heard of him yeah they
didn't want to pay for his hotel room so
I had to give up my rental car so he
could have a hotel room I so so I start
we start shooting these these scenes and
when you go on down as a director
especially to like a crew or a new place
you immediately get stink eye from the
crew like who's this guy coming in that
after the first scene I had one the crew
over like you know I was pretty funny
and so then I was just getting stink eye
from the producers which is normal on a
production so we're shooting we're
shooting and it was always the things
like okay well I'm gonna need three days
and two cameras and then it always goes
down too well you have one camera in two
days so all right I was expecting that
so when i went down i had the scenes
already plotted out and the the all the
dialogue everything planned so I shot it
I banged it out and Dean he's such a
professional like improvisers so he was
making every scene like amazing
and the producers didn't understand what
improv was so behind my back they told
all the only other actors that we love
what Dean's doing don't bother what
chris says just say whatever you want in
all the scenes oh god they just thought
anyone could do that yeah yes like in a
professional actor 20 30 years and the
rules of improv especially in a scene
are you know you stay in character you
don't yes a something from another scene
you don't you know you don't contradict
another plot point any of those things
and Dean makes it look effortless but
it's still clearly a skill to even the
untrained eye you could really tell that
this is a professional working so
finally it was done I edited it together
I was like you know what this is the
best that's gonna be it but it could be
of kind of a fun cult classic and you
know people know what they're getting
into it's like a mystery science theater
fun park comedy and it was supposed to
be rebranded as death of a horror movie
so people could get it and know what it
was that's cool I didn't hear from the
production company again for another six
to eight months and there's a law that
yeah they stopped returning my calls and
emails and then I find out from my fans
my fans email and say they found the
movie been reliance gate released it
never rebranded it still called it
asylum was marketing as a horror movie
so it's getting all these shitty reviews
on the internet for people from
basically har fans being duped into
watching this movie which I you know I
can't blame them like you you're getting
tricked your it's a baton so your stuff
that you shot down in Louisiana is in it
it's in there yeah and it's surprising a
lot of angry horror fans but when did it
come out it came out last year so it's
on it's on streaming it's on demand and
what's it what's it get on rotten
tomatoes so I don't know I didn't check
rotten tomatoes but it's got you know
what's funny it's still no matter how
bad the reviews are in IMDb and on
amazon it still got a higher rating than
any of kirk cameron's films there you go
yeah even the Lord is like yes never
seen that one I haven't seen that one
but uh the its a mix of reviews now
because now that our fans are
going to see it it's uh it's like
getting some five-star one's going if
you know the story behind this movie
it's hilarious all and then you've got
the one stores like I thought this was a
horror movie this is [ __ ] why these
the only um the only uh review that I
take offense to or exception with i
should say is that the the notion that
if it wasn't turned into a comedy it
somehow would have been a serviceable
horror movie oh no let me assure you
there was not even enough footage to
make a horror movie barely and let me
put it this way if a company like after
dark films thought this is unwatchable
it was unwatchable yeah so there was
literally nothing there to put together
and even like the editor had a good idea
because they wanted to take all the
stock footage out he goes you know we
could probably get a cheaper if we left
the little bug in there that said stock
footage in each section which would have
been really funny yeah I can see her
card right I would says stock footage
mmm but yeah so it's it's the only time
I think the same studio has ruined the
same movie twice like they they took out
half of mike schmitz really funny jokes
cuz they didn't get them like there's
one scene there's like a big boiler room
and it's like towards the end of the
movie X the Mike Schmidt makes a joke is
like oh is this the set of Metropolis
and then he waits for a second then it
goes you know Fritz Lang just turned
over in his grave because I mentioned
his film during this film that's right
no yeah they took it out like how yeah
you know our focus groups didn't get
their focus groups what are you talking
about you had applicable dumb interns
watch this and they didn't get it that's
what happened so somewhere out there
that there's a movie that exists that
shouldn't that has myself Mike Schmidt
Dean Hagelin Stephen Rhea and from The
Crying Game and a bunch of Baal
Bulgarian actors pretending to be a SWAT
tossing all together in one glorious
mess of asylum yeah it sounds like what
you that it could have been a cult
clapping if they don't would have
followed the plan i set out just this
could have been like a fun kind of you
know horror comedy you know what it
happened you got the story and no one's
been duped into seeing it you knew what
you were getting into and so is
you know you can't you wonder like what
that conversation was no it's better
that we just trick people and then
that's how we'll make the most money
women yeah like no it really isn't wow
so that's the thing a lot of people
don't understand that like I don't know
if we've talked about on here but you
know we have we all have friends that
have sold an idea or a show that they
like work their life at to get ya and
then the deal is yeah okay but there's
no guarantee that you're gonna be in it
and I like yeah yeah it's called the Jay
Larson yeah but like people don't get it
like you know as a as a writer and
director just because you our director
doesn't mean they're gonna let you
direct and if you're a writer create
actor creator doesn't mean you're gonna
get to be in it and people forget that
and then you can just see something just
just clearly you know what you don't
always get final cut that's for sure I
remember that scene in Barton Feeny
remember that movie when Barton figs a
screenwriter and the executives yelling
at him was like you think you only one
who could give me that Barton Fink
feeling just because you are barton fink
i thought you might have it in spades
that's like a John Woo movie isn't it
like uh that DS or something I think it
was yeah it was it was one of the Coen
brothers with uh oh god John Goodman is
so good in that movie is only a Nazi
he's so you all you've been a writer for
a while and I have just said you were
hired to write on the soap off I was I
was hired to write on so proper and then
I was like fun yeah Port Charles the
spin-off of General Hospital for Charles
i think i remember Port Charles we live
in New York no no it was shot here in LA
and it was I was temping on the lot it
was one of my temp jobs i was doing
computer support and I was fixing the
head writers computer and I said you
looking for writers like we're always
looking for writers so can you say we
burn them out yeah yeah exactly there's
that it's a bit of a turnover so I I
submitted a grace under fire spec so
yeah and they liked it every summer that
Brett Butler that was that was bring
about their yes as many years ago so I
they put me on trial so I started
writing but I was still keeping my
job is doing tech support so that was
going on for like about a month or two
been an executive at ABC figured it out
and sent my boss an email going he's
writing on the show and we have him in
the computer Department Weiss so well
Wow double dude yeah good for you they
because you should be if I'm doing two
yeah yeah [ __ ] exactly I'm don't too far
i was sitting in my computer office you
know writing the scripts right yeah so
occasionally we'll go out and fix
someone's computer but so I I was
working on the show then they hired me
full time my caps lock is stuck but he's
like Sonos ready he's like yeah you took
my baby you son of a [ __ ] I don't even
know your kids yeah it was like you know
oh it was great storylines like that it
was like you know serial killer is on
the run you know it's like well if you
escaped from prison if you're a serial
killer where would you go you would go
back to Port Charles of course you will
ya cuz we're not building any more sets
no yeah you know my whole idea of like
romance and love came from watching
soaps with my Nana every day was days of
our lives and Santa Barbara I fell in
love with the city of San Juan off that
I just thought that's what people did
you stay home from work yet sex with
your what you know I mean it was like a
hugely popular one yeah it was really do
so with days bro yeah yeah still on yeah
yeah there's a couple that are still
they've survived the the crunch so we
used to live in an apartment complex
where my brother and I we were the only
I so I'm telling you we're the only
white people on that floor and every day
since i worked at night I'd be home
during the day and I'd see all the black
girls talking like a lady's not girls
they were older single moms moms
whatever and uh it was always they
called him their stories like I'm away
oh yeah yeah I'm a non-story yeah and I
had to ask one of the girls one time
like what is what do you mean shucks
soaps I was like all your stories yeah I
didn't I let me watch my story there's a
there's a script every day had to be
written every single day every and those
actors man they gotta there's no prep
time you get your sides and you go out
there new shoe uh there's also no time
to tax anything either yeah there's
really no time to really think they're
doing a live one for a little while
something if there was like it would be
like a stunt kind of thing yet like this
one's live and but mainly it was it was
a factory turn in and out so they hired
me full time and I was just a diamond
cut you from the computer they could be
at her job yeah they're like all right
damn now i'm back to only one salary so
i'm writing and i'm just a dialogue
writer so what they would do is they
would give me the breakdown of like the
story for each episode and then i would
just write the dialogue so i would do
that for a while and then you know at
what happens in all shows and one of the
things that the head writer said is when
she hired me she said look you're
writing has a really distinct voice
which you know i think as a writer you
want to hear that that's a compliment
like and she said i want to make sure
that your writing comes through where I
don't even want to look at the title
page I want to read the script and know
that you're the one that wrote it and
she's like have you seen a silent yes
that's a little did I know what it was
held in store for me so I'm like alright
that's cool so I started putting some
jokes and I made him a little funnier
enemy you know I tried to lighten it up
a little bit and then I would watch like
the soap actors destroy and ruin all the
timing on every punch well sure because
they're not trained comedian or comedic
actors they're just trained to you know
repeat lines over and over and I found
out one interesting thing about soap
opera acting when you watch an actor
that's not very good on a soap opera but
if you watch them over a period of time
they suddenly become amazing because
it's not that they've gotten any better
you've gotten so used to them that I'm
like okay you know what it's pretty good
so as what happens with a lot of shows
is the you know the executive producers
clean house they fired the writer the
head writer that hired me they fired the
staff and I got called into the
executive producers office and she goes
to me you're writing has a very distinct
voice we don't want to hear it we want
all the writing like this is my story
channel
right here you know it seems like fire
writing you probably walk to the head
writers room pick the computer then is
hard so is it we want all the writing
just sound the same so I got fired for
the same reason just I got higher that's
great they didn't just tell you to stop
doing that they just like you're out it
has done especially because the other
the head writer hired you so we're
cleaning house you're gone to affects
the printer on your way out have you had
other staff jobs after that so I've had
for like freelance yeah and I did some a
lot of like punch-ups and some
screenplay stuff and a lot of stuff that
you know we get an assignment and like
how cool this is great this is gonna and
then never gets made and you know
there's a joke with writing is you know
I make a living writing for four people
yeah because you write your development
and it just never goes anywhere but I
liked being staffed especially on a show
like that because you weren't like
fighting in a writers room to get jokes
out and stuff you were just you know you
went in once a week for we a meeting you
did a dialogue and then like I would go
on the road sometimes just write the
scripts from there so but it was a you
know I don't I'll even rewriting them
over on Carrie Carrie yeah well there's
there's no Wi-Fi in Bulgaria yeah oh and
another budget yeah and then they
wouldn't let me say Bulgaria so I had to
change it to bovania in this crew are
you so heinous I'll be straight up with
you yet amazing country yes I've been
there a couple times yeah I'm like
really I can't say the actual don't know
we like you didn't put in Boca okay all
right it sounds like a disease sir you
have both ain't ya is it that's what you
have in your leg a couple months ago so
that was uh yeah that was an amazing TV
story man soaps about that yeah about
getting uh it was one of those things
too we're all just bounced to another
soap and then they all started
disappearing like there aren't that many
soaps i'll just say are there any left
now like still like General Hospital
still going days days they called a days
has to be still today yeah there's a
couple left foot
yeah you order to like it will will
those two ever really go away like you
think like now they're generational like
you know kids watch them with their
parents another are they watching what
their kids it's like I don't know it
it's a wonder if like they will be a
going on forever could you know I am we
were talking to you before you got here
professionally early by the way thank
you very much and we were talking about
marriage and blah blah yes on you had a
story about your honeymoon yeah I wanted
to hear if you wouldn't mind sharing
with us we'd get married we got married
actually in Philadelphia but we went to
honeymoon in a bunch of different places
they were new we summer in newark and
honeymoon and albany what are you from
Philly yeah from a suburb called
Westchester I went to school there went
to Temple University and then I came out
to LA to seek my fortune so and my
brother-in-law still doing my
brother-in-law runs a prep school out
there and uh like out near Villanova oh
really with the name of it malvern prep
oh yeah I've heard of Melbourne yeah a
lot of prep schools out there and that
the whole deal and Steve Simone tells
that there's like prep school central
out there I there's a lot of prep
schools and they prep you for like like
villanova meters go right over here yeah
you've clearly proven you can afford it
so now you're going to fill enough
Natalie yeah i went with two I've always
wanted to go to England and I went to
England we went to like some really cool
places went to London obviously and then
we went to a place called Glastonbury
which was really cool like a lot of like
cool like myth and mystic sites kind of
stuff South in there uh ball vania right
yeah yeah there's it's not there's an
underground railroad yeah and so went to
went to Scotland and went to Inverness
where you know we're Loch Ness is and
you could kind of see you know we wanted
to go on Loch Ness and you know and we
enjoy all like the legends and kind of
the just the fun tourism of all that you
go out on a boat we got on the boat we
look for the monster didn't find
but they were telling us that in Vernon
one day I'm just gonna come [ __ ] yeah
she pick as a tour guide mississauga's I
guarantee that's part of it then there's
you know there's like a there's an SE
museum it's fantastic it's great it's
like it's all and not a shred of
evidence anywhere that's the but not
it's all its 42 chorus it's great so
they did tell me though the the city we
were staying in inverness was one of the
most haunted places on the planet
there's myko planet yet to fold yeah
yeah what he said because of its violent
history and past it's literally haunted
like everywhere so I'm like all right I
just put this in the back of my mind and
the last couple days I sure to getting a
little sick i got like a cold and i was
having trouble sleeping and were in the
hotel room in inverness it's like the
middle of the night and the bed starts
shaking and I'm like yeah was it a nice
honeymoon yeah yeah and if it gives an
example of how violently you wish it
like was it violently shaking what kind
of shaking it was like a like a train
was going by what a vibration and then
it would stop so and my wife was asleep
[ __ ] didn't wake her up and then I
noticed out in the hallway I her started
hearing footsteps and every time the
footsteps would get near our door now
bed would shake again get the [ __ ]
I'm on dude is it like a boot or is it
like a heel it was a man or a woman it
sounded like a boot yes that's always a
food they don't ever wear chucks or
siding with it's a boot or the boot yeah
the only one to wear shoes in England is
Doctor Who what was the vote like from
what time period was the violent the
violin see violin hahaha like was it
like like the set like before Christ I
mean the 1200 s what we don't think it
was like literally this is kind of like
that that you know wars from the day
they said this is scott like literally
like every from Middle Ages on okay
constant think so and then the footsteps
would get farther away and then the
vibrating in the bed would subside
then uh the the footsteps would come
back towards the room and then the bed
would I would shake again so it happen
over and over and over and over only
times I was probably about three or four
times so I I tell your wife's asleep and
she's asleep but then that last time it
woke her up she was like 10 why is why
is the bed vibrating and then I was so
out of it wrap and cold and cold many he
don't worry about it this is our
honeymoon I got pinning a quarter go
back yeah so I was so out of it with
like cold medicine and feeling so shitty
that in my head the first thought in my
head was man i wish that ghost would go
away so I could get some sleep oh my god
so then I am I was like you know what I
turned the light on and then everything
[ __ ] stopped like I turn the light on
and then everything stopped the
footsteps stopped the bed stopped
shaking and then it was God just it was
done so the next day we woke up we went
to the front desk and I asked the clerk
I said is this hotel haunted and the
clerk goes no this hotel isn't confident
haunted well we're for three more night
yeah and then he goes what room were you
in so why would you ask me what room I
was in it was just that I wasn't run
yeah that's what but you know the luxury
squeeze no no just like I said what room
was I yet so we're in the honeymoon
suite Minh so clearly the hotel was on
it and then it did let slip that not
only you know you have this violent past
of this town said yeah the workmen died
a couple years ago here he like fell off
a ladder I liked it it's like pop it
fell off the ladder not somebody from
like yeah 1780 sure yeah so but that was
yeah that was it I really thought that
was like a real ghost story like that
was the first and only one I've ever had
did it just happen that one night that
was it yeah we were only in the hotel
for two nights and it just happened that
one night I was at the last night that
was the last night see I would have been
out of that I left Big Bear cuz of that
[ __ ] it works all the night oh did you
really after show I was like we're not
sleeping it right
yeah what it did you get like a taste of
something I had a the night before I had
this I you know people email me you had
sleep paralysis but I had a weight lay
on me and I couldn't move I couldn't
yell to get over there i'm wide awake
i'm fully aware of what's going on and I
huh then when I tell the lady who owns
the show home at the show because they
put you up in this house across the
street from the theater right that's
Cheryl Cheryl they said it's Ralph and
over Ella and it was a guy that had been
killed upon the floor above and that's
what they told me who it was and I was
like and then when I got back Donna said
Stella won't stop crying she's never
like this she's crying crying crying
crying crying and I tell her that story
and then we're like we're getting out
here about later we're not sleeping
there again yeah you think at what point
is it worth as comedians and a career
like you know what do I have to stay in
the Haunted condo yeah we can I Drive
home yeah all right yeah not even that
late at night i don't i don't have to
stay I mean I wonder if anyone just hit
him like you little [ __ ] the [ __ ] up
I'm like this autumn was saying told me
the next day she was quietly going show
me something that's what she said she
did and I was like it's your [ __ ]
fault that the man I prefer me yeah
while she was falling asleep was haunted
the ghost yeah that's what she told me
when we were driving back oh I kept
saying jeez but not on me but yeah you
might want to ask your wife if she
pulled that [ __ ] long back will you
whispering anything when we went to be
and then you know then of course she
starts telling all the stories from
other people and there's a book they
keep their that you go write your story
in so there's a log in a journal of
these old story but I'm guessing that
log is presented to you after your stay
yeah they don't tell you going it also
has to happen to you a want they want
you to come back she's like any time you
want to come up we'll give it to every I
was like I don't want to come back she
told me a story about one night she went
into the library where she obviously
doesn't keep candles and like them for
you know obvious I'm incensed right and
she said she woke up one morning she
smelled candles who are in the middle of
the night she smelled candles and she
went downstairs and she unlocked the
library that she always locks right when
she went in there were candles in there
and they had burned all the way down oh
and she's the only one in the house Wow
she was like [ __ ] I was like oh give
me I didn't take the gig cuz right they
asked like know anyone else where I
recommend me and the guy hit me up I'm
like I'm be straight up with you man I
did not think I do like I did that video
of other later to God like I'm just not
gonna look this solo no way it's not
worth it it is not worth it was of the
show was worth I mean I should have just
gone up done the show and gone back but
I mean really know we had a nice day and
everything a big bear likes beautiful
you got about you got around it for like
ghost hunters or something where they
can actually come and stay with you you
know something r you bring like a
paranormal crew up with you and make it
a thing yeah i'll be standing behind a
lot of people i'll be in the way in the
back in the middle actually what via the
back fear be a picked off easily like
Secret Service ghost car yeah yes um but
then you ran into some trouble we lay
that on the way back at our customs and
it was it's interesting to see it
escalates so quickly because my wife is
so she's so nice and innocent and she
didn't realize how much she was pissing
off the customs guy and I was like oh
please just stop stop talking so what
happened was we're getting our bags were
your ship it's not the ghost yes stop
being so nice what's wrong with you well
god oh yeah for sure step over here so
we get we get out of the you know we got
our bags and stuff and then the customs
agents have these drug sniffing dogs and
what they do is they walk around the
bags and all that stuff and then they
they sniff so the this is the dog sniffs
are a better job at and then the very
tiny little she's tiny little dog turns
around in the custom agent and that you
know just looks like this one you know
this but it's a tiny dog so they're not
usually the german shep now knows like
this was like a shih tzu aslam yeah it
was a tiny dog yeah and the customer
goes alright what do you got in your bag
it's like well not nothing just clothes
and stuff and
and you guys do you have any fruit nuts
or uh you know or see everything yeah
yeah or like coffee right here and so my
wife goes no no we don't we just have
you know we have mms and the custom
agent gets right nervine anemone goes
goes goes is this he goes eminem's is
like any go he actually gets in her face
it goes is that a fruit or a nut or a
vegetable and and now she gets mad she's
like it but you still in a nice way
she's like no but that's probably what
your dog is sniffing and then that's an
officer of the law and that's exactly
what I then the officer in his head
heard your partner's a [ __ ] it [ __ ] yeah
hey I'm challenging you and your Olympic
[ __ ] [ __ ] so this is a Bobby ya
know this isn't phil this is coming back
oh yeah not leaving England is coming
back in class so even of course
everything gets searched and then
there's nothing there and then we get
back and then we're walking out and then
my wife looks at me and goes you know
they were peanut M&MS a little dog got
written up for a false accusation I
haven't seen small dogs again doing it
in customs I've never seen I've only
just seen German Shepherds yeah yeah
that's all you see now so I know maybe
this was a pilot small dog program the
didn't wonder I came back from Seattle
this summer and actually you know I do
smoke marijuana and it's clearly legal
their statewide so I appreciated this
that what they did was they brought it
was a Labrador actually they brought it
through and sniffed everyone while we
were all waiting in line their bags
they're closed or whatever i'm assuming
because it's legal there people are
trying to get it out or whatever but it
just went right through but they didn't
just come by you once they zigzag
through with you so we'll come by you
maybe three or four times that would
come by just to make sure right and
they're like don't pet the it's a lab or
don't [ __ ] pet it but ever you
and Peter's being like don't pet it
dumped at it stars like to pet dog yeah
but then we didn't have to take off our
belt or shoes anything we just went
right through and I was like oh man they
should do that everywhere it was so
[ __ ] easy we didn't have to undress
or do all that [ __ ] but what if it
was a dog sniff mighty mighty look it up
like this yeah but they're not always
just doing that for weed no I'm saying
whatever reason it was bombs weed
whatever i'm all for it easier to get
through yeah we zip we walked what
because everyone's just going through
here sure you running tsa PreCheck no
I'm never um there's not no one [ __ ]
gone I gotta have my computer out of the
[ __ ] bag running on my belt gonna
come off by the way I forgot to take my
Shaffer pre-check it's worth it yeah
well I mean sometimes they just throw
you in there just randomly you know yes
randomly throw people through pre-check
we're just well which is very stupid
because it's randomly I'm randomly gonna
get you through quicker that's how
adverse this isn't America's people like
which way do I go it should be like how
freakin you fly it should all be like in
a number system like Oh percentage-wise
oh you flew 60,000 miles last year
you're not pre check but boom you go
three can go in crazy Nate bargatze just
had a great bit on found the other night
about being in a small airport so it
didn't have like the x-ray you just go
through the thing and he goes this guy
goes through and the guy goes uh the
alarm goes off it was half I don't know
what it could be and the guy goes well
you know he goes look at the guy goes
you think it was my belt and and Nate
goes if your family feud and the
question was what would make a metal
detector go off the number one answer
would be belt yeah it's probably your
belt but i'll just take your word for it
go ahead sir yeah um so you went the
film school at temple I did yeah Temple
University a few years to you you play
anywhere else I didn't know I actually
started as an engineering major I was
going to go to drexel and then I my dad
actually worked at a community college
in pennsylvania so since they didn't
want to pay for two years of college
junior college yet I was like well
you're going there and then transfer him
like all right so I was going to
transfer to drexel and be
engineer and then after two years of
college I went I don't want to be an
engineer know what I'm going to go into
film and that's when I went to film
school in a temple university but it was
old school Film School where you would
actually have to cut your film with a
razor blade on a block yeah tape and
they don't still do that in all film
school they they don't everything is
digital now every once in a while
they'll do that is like an exercise yeah
in futility but there's no reason at all
anyone should be doing that at all ever
so well it wasn't even efficient because
the razor blade was stronger than the
block you would cut on so the block
would actually start to degrade and have
like little grooves where the reasonably
we get so you couldn't even cut it
properly and then I remember like the
big expensive system that the grad
students got to use was the steam bec in
the other room that was like the real
real that would go around really fast
and this was way before digital editing
although the biggest part of digital
editing that we did was a VHS to VHS
good yeah that was like we would get VHS
tapes and then we would edit and
together for one a big new VHS tape and
no matter how skilled you were at it no
one could ever adjust the tracking
properly yeah so it was it's interesting
to see like all the stuff that you know
we we were taught and learned on is
100-percent completely obsolete gone
yeah it's everything's everything's
digital every isn't that how they had an
asylum yeah I wish it would have been
easier yeah I had a professor i was
telling you and in college that uh was a
radio guy and I mean long-gone was real
to reel editing cutting just like that
but yeah I made because he was a
dinosaur he made us going on a [ __ ]
Saturday and cut and you couldn't just
this was part of your grade you couldn't
just cut it had to be a clean edit and
the same problem with the blocks and
everything you couldn't have that
problem you couldn't have a little noise
and mall in there or anything couldn't
be clipped yeah he would tell you to
pull this together and this together you
had to go in there and slice and [ __ ] on
a Saturday and it took forever it took
forever and then did you had to add like
the real
real sound and try to sink that up to
you know we don't have to do that this
was just a straight edit oh that's it
yeah yeah then we had the after you did
the blocks we would have quote the sound
synchronizer that it would be another
obsolete machine that then the this this
the real real sound would go on you can
never get that right either and you
wonder like if this is how professional
people are making movies how is anything
in sync ever so because they had steam
bags so I graduated from film school and
came out here so you knew it like what
agent you wanted to get into film did
you like 13 yeah you want to write or
you want a director you wanted to act I
never wanted to act I always just wanted
to write and direct in fact I put out a
short film compilation a couple years
ago and it had like my first movie that
i made in that I when I was 13 on it was
like a little stop motion animation cool
but I just used my toys and blob and
then the person i worked with their 13 a
childhood friend became a sound designer
later so he went back and sound designed
the entire thing like 30 years later
sounds cool so it actually sounds good
good now because he added the soundtrack
many many years later but it was a it's
cool it's one of the things I love about
filmmaking over the place it really
slows and post up yeah exactly 30 years
Jesus for a two minute edit ocean but I
always loved telling stories and that
that was always been my first love and I
always think like that's the only the
best part about stand up for me has
always been just kind of the writing
more than the other performing or acting
Sharon interesting well you know I've
been like I have tons and tons and tons
of old like stand-up sets and I've just
been going through them cuz like I just
want to put more content out like of
jokes that never like I did on TV I'm
like let's get these jokes out and I'm
looking back to when like I don't know
maybe I was like six or seven years in
or eight years in a comedy I'm like man
my writing was like so much better than
like I wrote just like I just don't
write anymore I just get up my god I can
talk about this and you can just see
comics that right and how much stronger
they are because they wrote the jokes
and then
and everything else comes afterwards you
know what I mean like you can just see
the difference in comics when you see a
guy get up there that's like a look at
that that's clearly written and and
times put into it you know right i also
used to know a guy's the babysitter's
guy were first moved out here who was a
VP at Warner Brothers in film he was out
how old was he how old was he he was
like oh 13 min made the stop motion
video um for his kid this guy was like
baller like he was up there he was doing
big things and he used to I told you
know he knew that I wrote and he used to
ask me like how's your writing and
that's all right he was like writers
always work man you can't make anything
without a writer you know what I mean
like you can always get rid of like
someone you know I mean but you're
always gonna need the people to write
things I think what he meant to say is
the same six writers always working yeah
i saw cool TED talks today I never watch
my buddy scented of the guy that wrote
like toy story and finding nemo and it's
the whole TED talk is about writing and
like storytelling and stuff like that
anyway if you have a chance go check out
definitely baller the guy is killer to
teach and he was you saying earlier but
like you said it like 40 minutes ago how
like you always take something from your
life it comes out in your right hand and
he he was making a point about that and
told the story about when he was four
years old that happened with his dad and
then showed a clip from Nemo when the
dad finds Nemo's like just as a little
egg when he lost them in the ocean and
it was like that was something that
happened to him in his life is crazy
yeah yeah it's cool so is that what
inspired you to write your book what's
called pacify me yet yeah that that is
literally autobiographical that one a
handbook for the freaked-out new dad
yeah I wrote it and I was when my wife
got pregnant I was just freaking out I
was like my life is over I can't I don't
know I want to have kids but I don't
really want them now but it's I'm
getting older I have to have and so I
started like picking up books about
being a dad and like well this is crap
this doesn't help me oh this is written
for a woman or it's written like it's a
woman talking to a dead where it's it's
a basically the advice to new dads on
all these women
how to expect you're expecting books is
like what you just need to support the
woman that's all the advice for dads and
I was like well this is garbage there's
nothing here that's helping me or
helping me get through this or is from
my perspective so I wrote one and I
wrote the proposal and I had a friend of
mine Stephanie Wilder Taylor who was
writing a bunch of mommy books and she
sent it to her editor at Simon &
Schuster and they bought it so it came
out in two thousand in Bulgarian to yeah
yeah oh it's yeah it's this banner year
now I will say this is the one project
though that I had control over and had a
great experience and I was like wow and
I knew enough about Hollywood and how
projects worth this may never happen
again you know and I wrote it and its a
mix of like getting over the fear of
being a dad and then becoming loving
being a parent and also but
acknowledging the fact that you're
freaked out like the initial title the
book was my life is over and the
publisher is like that might be a little
too negative women may not buy that for
their husbands so we changed it to
pacify me that first chapters still
called my life is over so haha the
choice so it goes through that and then
I wanted to do also give like tips and
helps help parents especially dad so I'm
kind of getting through the the process
and so it goes up pretty much from
getting pregnant to the birth to the
first year life and that's that's the
book and I've gotten some really great
feedback on it like people have emailed
me and said look no one else was kind of
talking about what I was going through
but your book helped me get through this
and then there are some people that are
furious like how could you be so nagging
you talk about pregnancy and having a
baby like this that's awful I'm glad my
husband doesn't think this and like when
we kind of does he just keeps his mouth
shut yeah you know he gave me a
five-star review yeah yeah so it was a
really funny road right yeah yeah yeah
we go out he's told me an earful about
you so it was a it was really a good
experience because it was it was very
cathartic for me to get everything out
but it was also great to hear like you
know as we joke around and
artists and stuff but ultimately if we
help somebody through a tough time like
you know you guys I'm sure get it all
the time the podcast helps people and
that's really rewarding when we hear
stuff like that I agree it when we do we
have great fans we do get it quite a bit
and I uh yeah it feels good so that is
out that you can it's on kindle and your
kids are how long now they are 11 and 7
and then my daughter is discovered
acting and I've been trying to
discourage it for she 11 or seven she's
11 she's the 11 year old and but she's a
singer dancer actor and she's the lead
in Greece she's sandy for the school
play an 11 happen so bad so it's so
funny too because like as you guys know
how miserable the business can be she
was like you know I want to get an agent
going on in like no no you're too young
it's it's it's not what you think it's a
lot of rejection wait till you're older
and then you know another year went on
she kept bugging me and bugging me
bugging like okay you also she was
hitting you up she was at me up at like
five Wow and I was like let's you know
let's wait wait I want cuz i also wanted
to see is this something she really
wants to do or is this because of you
know kids in LA that's one of the things
that used to talk about what candy they
like but kids now I like Oh what who's
your agent will you got an audition this
isn't grade school this happened it's
insane so so finally actually I'm like
all right so if you really want to do
this and she wanted to take acting
classes they have a real strong
theatrical program actually in her grade
school so I set her up with two meetings
with a for Cameron yeah yeah exactly
they they both they both wanted her so
we signed with one agent and I'm like
she's summoned she's got signed across
the board Wow for everyone she's got a
new book coming out called yes if I hard
to get and then I said now look you're
gonna go on auditions you're not it's
gonna be miserable you're not gonna get
a lot of stuff and then she booked at
NBC promo Wow so I'm like all right
clearly you want to do this you seem to
be fairly good at it then we'll continue
and see how [ __ ] see
resent me so far so she's doing uh she's
doing well that's what I talked to you
know sometimes we have her on the
podcast we do like a spoiler up for like
a kid's movie and then with graham her
and myself in the room only one of us
has representation across the board oh
my god sorry dad I can do the podcast a
call back she's got a Cheetos call back
so she don't that's amazing well fancy
this if it's too personal you can don't
tell me have you guys had the birds and
the bees talk is that did your wife have
that are you gonna have that or has it
been had that's a lot of questions you
just asked me well that one and i'm
going to say i don't know my wife's
department perfect so it's very possible
it's been said and I've made it very
clear I don't want to know when it
happens but just let me know and I can
plan accordingly for the weekend for a
new book yeah I know we have a son the
seven-year-old son is that I'll take
care of him it's like we're gonna have
to split up you know this is you
understand how the parts work better
than I do and I don't even know like I
remember we learned in like it was
middle school yeah you know but I think
it starts earlier and earlier it was way
earlier now and you also didn't grow up
in I mean where you grew up outside of
Philly but ya la and internet equals
yeah forget it yeah just like I know
like I think internet before the my
daughter mentioned that like in fifth
grade that like you know at tours andia
they'll get a kit I'm not exactly sure
what's going to be in it but it's part
of their educational process that's a
theory yeah I remember fifth grade
getting like a prep video see when I in
six grades when we got the boys and
girls were separated and we all had to
talk I like the word kit cuz it's just
something about a model airplane you
know it's yeah there was this dude Alan
Carr he's a British comic not the guy
that like there's a big this two of them
i'm pretty sure I'm pretty I can't
remember exactly but I saw him one time
he's a gay guy and he goes up
he goes you remember sex education class
girls will go to one room talk about
their periods boys would go to another
room learn how to put a condom on it was
always very awkward waiting for mr.
Jenkins dick to get hot the best jobs
ever heard singing have to go through it
or your wife's gonna yeah we're all my
world yeah I've got to go through it you
know so i can see ride doing it I can
see why don't ya rise not gonna be
scared she's a dash of like listen I'm
telling listen to me Dakota yeah or tap
haha dad I tell you look at your kids
growing up and you think about that and
you just hear in your head like tick
tick tick tick tick no it'sit's govern
you can't the only thing that concerted
that gives me anxiety about that is the
age being earlier than I want it to be
in my head cuz that's just realistic and
it's just the way it is you're talking
about yeah probably about that now
eleven twelve yeah it's crazy there are
only two that we you know we never used
to deal with like the constant barrage
of devices and machines and yeah and all
these things it's like well who's
texting you is you know what chat rooms
are you in and all that stuff you gotta
monitor everything now there's there's
too many screens to monitor yeah anymore
so I just have to learn how to lock down
everything yeah yeah that's true you
know it's a you know you say you have to
childproof the house you gotta kind of
childproof the technology right you know
until somebody at their schools like 09
how to break that you know they make a
figure out a workaround I remember
Howard Stern laying it out really well I
mean years ago he was talking about
those chat rooms and he was you know
telling them just just like there are
predators in real life they exist in
there too and he was trying to monitor
right what rooms they couldn't couldn't
be in and yeah it's almost impossible
there's always a workaround to something
well I you know I'm probably gonna need
the FBI to break into my daughter's
phone so they parently Apple don't let
that they got somebody who can do it
that's um well we're about that time
here Chris Mancini thank you very much
oh this was great coming on here and
will you please one more time promote
and plug your Kickstarter and all that
absolutely it goes to May second is a
graphic novel to be at least 140 pages
and it's called long ago and far away
you can just go to Kickstarter and type
in long ago and far away there's some
great rewards you get the whole book you
can get it digitally and there's like a
real if you go up high to like like five
thousand dollars if you want to go that
high it's kind of a giveback tier where
I talk to the artist if you want to make
your own comic book will make ten pages
of it for you I'll write it and he will
actually allow color it and letter it so
if you're thinking like you know I want
to kind of do this myself and I've got I
want to support this artist and then
like yeah will support it right back so
we'll do it again there's some cool
comedy film nerds tears where we'll go
to a movie with you and we'll do a
spoiler up with you afterwards so talk
so it's long gone far away it's got
until May second we could really use
your help on it the other thing I want
to say is some people like wow I don't
really have any money five bucks isn't
going to make a difference it really
does if you only have five bucks to give
it still needs to get us there because
it's a 28 thousand dollar goal and as of
what we're taping is we're already over
10 grand which is good so we're almost
halfway that's 28 grand in Bulgaria
exactly like that's like 10 million I
gdansk ease or whatever dad's don't even
talk about how far that goes in bovania
so and we do ship to bovania so you can
you can still participate and uh LA pod
fest what's will dates were excited to
be a part of it that is yeah happy to
have you guys back 23 to 25 at the
sofitel hotel it's going to be a really
big year this year we've got 23 to 25
volt month September's um that's a
surprise and we got like welcome to
night Vale criminal roosterteeth a lot
of really big podcast and some of them
there overlap with comedy but some
different type stuff too so we want to
really just kind of open it up and cool
I really to go a cool podcasting
experience for the fans great awesome
man well thanks for coming on I was a
pleasure to have you uh someone come on
share such great stories man cool thanks
for having me guys as always Jay Larson
comedy calm Jay Larson comedy on all
social media Ryan
calm Ryan Sickler on social media will
talk to you all next Tuesday